[Applause]
hundreds of thousands of people showed
up in the nation's capitol Saturday for
the women's march on Washington
they were always barriers and glass
ceilings and wooden and iron doors to
get through you can't get caught up in
the the madness of hate and anger and
it's not gonna be easy there's gonna be
lots of challenges you know I'm sure
there'll be frustrating days I'm sure
there'll be times I cry because I don't
mind crying by the way but I'm hopeful
while we have victims or survivors
coming forward and saying me too
we need men to say I did that I don't
know who said it but Pandora's Box is
opened and Pandora is pissed we were
making a movie about someone who wants
to teach love and truth in the world
right now and who's incredible and want
to live up to everything of a superhero
movie I feel like I was born to teach at
this school they come to school for you
no one's ever put it that way all that
is happening is bickering and fighting
you know we had kids that bicker and
fight and we saw that every day the
Republican Party has so many Republican
women clubs everywhere and they are
actually the heartbeat of everything
social structures and these
infrastructures in schools and in our
communities that are pushing away from
this intersectionality of being a black
person and a woman and a girl and
they're not including all of us as the
neutral means to go and see refugee
children he needs to go and visit the
refugee camps he needs to know what a
real life is like in a refugee camp my
focus now is really to be the best first
captain I can be regardless of gender or
race I've seen things that I thought
would never change change and so that's
really exciting and I'm really proud and
I want to honor sort of the women that
came before me